[Music]
all right today is the 31st
anniversary of his radio show in the eib
network joining us now
from eib southern command is the rush
limbaugh 31 years i think mary matt
won years and i mean it's flat out
amazing and you know it
time has is like everything time has
raced by
on certain things and other days it's
just been slow
and plotting but man am i blessed we all
are this is
it's it's such a great opportunity to
have to be able to
talk about these things that really
matter the future of the country with
with so many millions of people it's
really really really been a an honor and
it's ongoing
it's uh there's still nothing i do sean
uh that i get more enjoyment out out of
than this so and also
appearing on fox you know i've i've been
i've been very blessed to be invited
here by you and i can't thank you enough
for having me on
russia i i think you got the greatest
compliment ever
from mary matlin i think it was after
the clinton years she goes
i don't know how we would or survived
but you being there every day i think a
lot of conservatives including myself
feel that way
well it's been a lot of time um but
it's interesting if you go back started
in 1988
and in 1988 sean there was nothing
but the three networks and the two big
newspapers
and cnn and that was it and that and in
terms of conservatism in the media would
probably be
national review william buckley's
magazine uh bob terrell of the american
spectator that was
it the think tanks of course but none of
them were media and then for
four years there wasn't anything it was
me and me on tv then then then you got
your show another conservative started
appearing on
on radio and it just built and built
finally fox goes on the air
in uh in 1996 but during that clinton
campaign
not to brag but mary madeleine was right
there wasn't anything else except
us on the radio doing battle with with
that
and it's it's just it's amazing to think
back to all the things that have
happened
and where we are i played a clip of
myself today
on charlie rose in 1992. this is
27 years ago and and i'm talking he
wants to know why i think
radical environmentalists are actually
socialists
and he thinks i'm full of it he's having
a lot of fun with me he's laughing this
is the
days when when these people used to
invite me on their shows when they
thought i was harmless you know fun like
a circus act
uh to have on but he these people had no
idea of the seriousness that we brought
to this but 26
27 years ago and here today in that
debate last night
andrew yang i think i think i can't
believe this has not gotten
more reaction andrew yang
said we're too late we don't have time
anymore
it's time to move our people to higher
ground
yeah i remember talking about climate
the higher ground
uh stop and think about that move our
people to higher ground then jay ensley
came out and admitted what all of this
climate change is he said
every progressive liberal issue is
wrapped up in climate change and
it is climate change is what allows them
to poison the minds of young kids to
blame
people for causing a problem and then
offer them redemption make them
feel like they have meaning in their
lives by saving the planet
it's gotten to the point these people
actually have convinced people that we
can change the weather
that we can change the temperature and
none of this is true
it's literal lunacy and insanity that
has become mainstream
on that side of the aisle and they're
going down
the tubes with it and it's it's
remarkable it's remark i watched that
debate last night i'm on the floor
laughing uh
through through so much of it yeah you
you know it's bad when rahm emanuel has
to go
on tv today and criticize these people
for being nuts
with with this agenda uh i mean gloria
borger on cnn after the debate
where was the inspiration where was the
espares
there isn't any hands people need to
understand how the democrats see
american this is the thing
that just boggles my mind they look out
over this landscape
they see nothing but suffering they
don't see anybody
other than in pain victims of this
victims of that then they position
themselves as the people are going to
fix it
and get even with the other people us
who have caused
all of this misery and it there isn't
anything they talk about that involves
improving life they talk about
jobs not careers they do not offer
anybody anything uplifting and they
haven't
created a group of voters that even
thinks uplifting
their voter group is mired in all kinds
of misery
injustice uh to the point they're
covering up george washington and murals
in san francisco
rather than cleaning the human feces off
the streets out there
it's an amazing thing to see how this is
all transformed
your guests just before me on this show
stop and think of it
three years ago about then nobody
thought that donald trump could win i'm
talking about in the mainstream the
media the
washington establishment nobody thought
he could win
tonight nobody thinks anybody on that
democrat debate stage can win
stop in just three years we've gone from
a a candidate that everybody was
laughing at and thinking had
no prayer and wasn't even serious about
winning
to now nobody on the democrat side is
they're asking michelle obama to get in
and say
if they're doing that that's a
tantamount admission that nobody they're
running now
has a slight chance or even a prayer let
me
ask you so my buddy bill cunningham you
know bill from cincinnati radio talk
shows great guy funny
um so he's telling me they're lined up
at six in the morning to see the
president
um i was you you were gracious enough
you invited me to your wedding
the only people you see lined up around
the block for long periods of times
usually
can sing well play piano or guitar
explain the trump phenomenon versus what
we're seeing here
well i did the trump phenomenon you mean
why people have glommed on to him and
it's it it goes back i think to the
differences
that the democrats and us that we
have in the way we see the country you
know we
we conservatives and i'm going to take
the opportunity of this
stellar appearance tonight to remind
people who conservatives are we love
everybody we love
people we see a sea of potential as we
look out over the country we want people
to be
the best they can be we want people to
be happy
we realize what a blessed opportunity it
is to be born
in the united states of america and we
want everybody
to maximize their potential because
that's how you get a great country
that's how you get great innovation
that's how you get great modernization
it's how you get a great military
it's how you get a great anything is
great people
it's the people of this country who make
it work now the democrat party
that's just a foreign language to them
those kind of people stop and think this
is really true those kind of people are
of no
use to the democrats the democrats are
threatened by people
who can rely on themselves they're
threatened by people who can take care
of themselves they're threatened by
people
who because those people are not
dependent those people are not going to
be
in need those people are not running
around trying to figure out
who it is that's responsible for their
unhappiness and their misery
they're too busy taking advantage of the
blessed opportunity to live
in this country and not not everybody is
but the point is we have freedom to be
and do whatever we want the democrats
want to put
obstacles in people's way the left wants
to shackle people
because they don't believe in people
they don't believe in freedom and
liberty because they don't trust people
they think most people are
decrepid and and dishonest
and racist sex is big and homophobic and
it's such a gigantic contrast
i don't know how in the world anybody on
that side
thinks that they're going to put
together a majority
to win a national election with that
kind of an agenda which thinks this
point
america is not great america is not
exceptional
america is immoral and unjust and has
been since our founding how do you build
any kind of a genuine serious movement
on that kind of
attitude about the country so we we
talked about this phenomenon where
people will wait in the pouring rain
20 hours to see donald trump that's
because trump appeals
he appeals to people in the way that i
just talked about he appeals to people's
better interests this is what people
don't understand about donald trump they
get caught up in the tweets they get
caught up in all the
the manners that he supposedly didn't
have the man touches
everybody's hearts talking about
greatness talking about
inspiration aspirational living being
great
everybody wants that everybody wants to
improve their life for their family for
themselves
he touches me he's got a bond with with
his
voters that nobody can break he's got a
bond that
it's it's innate not everybody can
create this bond there's not a democrat
on that stage
either night that has any kind of a bond
with anybody in the democrat party trump
is untouchable there's not one person
sean
on that democrat stage the last two
nights that can even
be on stage with trump and not be
overshadowed simply by his presence
before he even opens his mouth
but still russia you know but you we
follow elections this is our life this
is what we do we live eat breathe sleep
this
for any republican to win the presidency
they always have to thread the needle
florida
north carolina mark meadows state ohio
you got to pick off michigan wisconsin
pennsylvania
um it's the it's it's not it's never
going to be easy and there's always that
appeal oh
we'll take all your fear away and
everything will be taken care of
well yeah i guess maybe i've been at
this for so long and i
i do have to remind myself that they
have a lot of supporters that that's one
of the scary things you watch the debate
last night
and you hear this lunacy and it was
lunacy it was it was
genuine if if if you can define
normalcy in any which way we would have
in common those people are lunatics
the things they were saying and
believing and then you realize that
people are applauding it
i mean i was warning people 20 years ago
when when some wacko thing would happen
the environment people laugh nobody's
ever going to believe that they said
now here we are they do believe and i
understand the threat here
let me give you an example of of i think
where we have a golden opportunity
tulsi gabbard tulsi gabbard came out of
nowhere last night because she reamed
kamala harris
now what is the media doing today i love
this
guess what to explain tulsi gabbard they
are saying i saw this on cnn sean
they're saying that she's actually
working with the russians
who are still working with trump no and
her
game plan is to become a third-party
independent candidate
to split the democrat vote they started
this russian insanity and now they're
wedded to it they can't let go
of it and there's nothing in it for them
on this there's no
winning with it i don't believe now i'm
not a political professional
when you talk about threading the needle
in all these states i just say
just have trump be trump just appeal to
people their better interests and he can
permeate this noise like he did
in 2016. three words i want to throw at
you
green new deal
well uh it it's
it it is a trick the green new deal even
uh alexandria ocasio-cortez
her chief of staff said cracked secrets
to crop whatever check robardi
admitted that it's not even about the
about the climate it's not even about
the weather it's an economic plan
and it is it's designed to get
massive federal power grow the federal
government
under the pretense that average
americans cannot
be left to live their lives without
ruining things especially for the
democrat party
it's it's unaffordable it will never
happen and the premise behind it
is bogus there is no man
made climate change there is nothing we
can do
to stop whatever the weather is going to
do we can't make it warmer we can't make
it colder
we can't change hurricanes directions we
can't dissipate them
we can't create them and yet they're
they're they're campaigning and trying
to convince people
i mean look at millennials it's really
sad there's a lot of young people that
really think this planet is not going to
be habitable
by the time they hit 65. these people
are ruining people's lives
they're ruining their futures all in the
pursuit of power for themselves
it really it's disgusting on one level
to me
and i think they need to be called out
and i think they need this stuff needs
to be
said point blank to them uh because the
media is not the
the media is their best buddies the
media is their their their
support group and so forth it's a big
battle i'm just i'm i'm just
optimistic i'm confident that these
people can be beat back because then
they're getting nuttier and nuttier
every day
and they're demonstrating we don't have
to tell people are getting nutty
they're showing us 31 years
uh broadcast excellence well it's i mean
this is a milestone i remember when i
first heard about you
i was i started in radio in 1987.
i was in a college radio station guy
comes with you give here this guy rush
limbaugh
in santa barbara california and you
created a huge firestorm out there
there was a barbecue place that
boycotted you and you
sent all of your listeners into the
barbecue place and they they came back
um uh so uh 31 years it's amazing
accomplishment and you're right about
conservatives hey look you were my
you're my first guest host
sean we've kind of been in this all
together you know we
we we've been connected uh since this
all started it's it's
look i know time is limited here and
sometimes people accuse me of being
a little too pollyannish and not and not
aware enough of the pitfalls you just
talked about threading the needle i'm
not
i'm not naive i know how difficult it is
i'm not i'm not trying to claim this is
going to be easy
i want people to look at the democrats
i'm sick and tired of being afraid of
these people i'm sick and tired of
people acting intimidated by democrats
especially this current crop there's no
reason to fear these people
i know they have the media on their side
donald trump doesn't fear them
donald trump doesn't let them intimidate
him donald trump is showing
how people on our side can win for the
first time in
in many many years that i've been doing
this he's showing people
every day how to win and there's an art
to knowing how to win
not just play the game and not just be
on the stage
and the democrats are making themselves
gigantic
targets here this russia thing has blown
up in their face
the media is not telling anybody but it
has they've got
nothing all the lawsuits are being
thrown out now
cohen was thrown out the the thing that
was thrown out earlier this week there's
nothing we've been in a race
this business with comey i know
everybody's upset that it looks like
comey's gonna walk i have faith
i have faith that the people doing this
investigation
are going to hold these people
accountable uh
for three years two years we've been
hearing that all this is going to come
to fruition and a lot of people are
frustrated
disappointed they were today when it was
when it was said that comey's not going
to be prosecuted for all reasons because
he didn't intend
to do it there has to be accountability
here and i think
that it's going to happen great timing
for the 2020 election let's just see
i agree with all that i actually see
similarities between
you and trump let me tell you what two
of them are
um number one you got to be able to take
a punch
you paved the way for a lot of us that
are conservatives in the media
you've taken more than your fair share
and then you've got to fight for what
you believe
my biggest criticism of republicans is
they are
weak a lot of them and timid and afraid
to do what you do every day to do what
trump is doing you're right
showing them the way just fight for what
you say you're going to fight for
i well look there are two different
things going on i i don't have to get
votes
you and i can succeed with people hating
is
people or disliking us but people a lot
of them rush
get elected but people who need
to win elections people that don't like
you don't
vote for you so i understand their
reticence a bit but i think
that can be overcome with attitude it
can be overcome with confidence
i it's fear of the media this fear of
being called a racist
everybody needs to get over that now
because all of us are racists
everybody's they can't talk about
anybody now without labeling them racist
this thing that trump did about
baltimore it's about time this stuff is
called out
where the democrats run cities or towns
or states
with one party rule those places are
suffering
greatly the people there are suffering
drug addiction they're suffering drug
infestation
and they're suffering filth and nobody
ever calls them out under because you
can't because the democrats supposedly
are the ones with compassion so you
can't criticize them
the heck with that they deserve to be
criticized they deserve to be called out
it was cummings himself 20 years ago
you everybody's seen the video now who
referred to his own city
as drug infested and nobody said it was
racist back then
trump is is really showing a lot of
people
how to take these people on um you know
we've got this never trumper problem
that that uh
i think is kind of like an elephant a
fly on an elephant's ass
but people make it out to be bigger than
it is because these were supposedly the
intellectual leaders of our party
they've been rendered irrelevant they
know it that's why they're ticked off
uh they're probably going to vote
democrat if they have a chance simply
because you know how they're going to
sell cruises now
to tell people what to think about
conservatives but for 20 years they
thought they were the intellectual
leaders of conservatism
they never got much done yeah i know
we're out of time i'm sorry about this
diary of the mouth with you sean cause i
like being here i should
i should have just given you a whole lot
31 years i want to just tell people one
fact
when you started in syndication there
were less than 200 talk
radio stations in america now there are
thousands
rush happy anniversary thank you so much
for being with us thanks sean